so I spent all day pouring over our
comedians social media feeds you should
all be very ashamed of yourselves so
mom's I'm going to show you a downright
horrible tweet for one of these filthy
hooligans and I was like you know ring
in and tell me which one of your damn
delinquent sons wrote it first up this
one super embarrassed actually sent my
mom for depicts she only asked for two
which one of your Karen I say it's Ron
because I remember when he had his was
circumcised when I was 13 yeah and it
cost like fourteen hundred dollars I
want to keep you know on progresses oh
my god an investment it's an investment
go run essentially is working all this
time just to pay off his penis and
installments here's the answer I'm sorry
that's not a correct answer yes Vicki
I'll say it's Randy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it was yes or less or no point yes sir
how do you explain this I was an
accident because I was trying to send
them to my uncle okay hi I think my mom
accidentally ate my weed candy let's see
where this goes before I could even
finish
do I need to just give you points
automatically Aaron yeah was Gumby you
know love gamma gamma what happened I
can tell you turns out it wasn't an acne
my mom just cool
[Applause]